[Music]
you're gonna need a bigger boat
well not as threatening as the shark in
jaws
another creature is causing quite a stir
in a minnesota lake
and it's not gray and white but gold
giant goldfish some the size of a
football
have become a regular site in keller
lake a 50-acre body of fresh water
located just south of minneapolis
in the town of burnsville the creatures
are not
native to these waters instead they may
have been dropped in the lake
by local pet owners and actually a lot
of biological invasions
started with people releasing their pets
into the wild
and once they're out it's it's difficult
and expensive to control them
as to their enormous size they may have
started as the small goldfish were used
to seeing
nature took it from there university of
minnesota professor
shemik bajer is the owner of carp
solutions the company that conducted a
fish survey of the lake
fish can really adapt to their
environment so if they have a lot of
food
if they have the right temperature and
not much competition they can grow quite
large
unfortunately that growth is at the
expense of other creatures
members of the carp family goldfish are
bottom feeders
uprooting plants and starving out native
species
but damage has already been done here in
many other waterways around the world
where goldfish have also taken hold
as for the future of the fish in keller
lake if they're not becoming abundant
they'll just stay in that lake
because it's extremely difficult to
eradicate them
don't dump your goldfish i was just
gonna say don't that's fine just don't
don't don't yeah but can you eat them
sure that's the solution if you want to
sure but they wanna you wanna want me to
grill one up for you today yeah let's
try
fine